can't play baseball but not swing that
bad I eat crippled
tag game bottom of the night at bat
Ricky Hill
[Music]
oh my gosh what did you do let's go
Ricky I've seen you out there swinging
that stick even when you're suffering
pain
but you can't play baseball you're gonna
get rid of him
and you're gonna wind up with an injury
that you'll never get over God's Gonna
Give You a higher calling but all I want
to do is play when I swing that bat I
ain't crippled no more
Ricky
I did four homers in one game
teams are rapidly
between this Major League trials you're
gonna paralyze him I don't need you
feeling him full of false hope he's my
son
Ricky baseball had to end eventually
time to figure out what you gonna do
with the rest of your life first time
you ever talk to me like a man is to
tell me to forget the only thing I ever
loved
what has gotten into you he's special
she said he was
your plan to join the elite I'm one of
the best hitters you're ever going to
see the bad Lake across the team wins
and money it's all stacked against me if
you don't try you're gonna die inside
I want my dreamer back
all your hopes I cannot do this alone
three it's your time Ricky
termination and sacrifices have come
down to this
[Music]